I've said before that voting Donald Trump
out is only the beginning.
And the analogy I used was that for the last
three and a half years, we've essentially
been playing defense.
We haven't had the ball.
We've been trying to get the ball back.
If Donald Trump is removed by Joe Biden and
becomes the next president and Joe Biden becomes
the next president, we haven't scored.
We've just gotten the ball back.
And that's when the fight will will really
begin.
And it's important to flush this out a little
bit now because we're now only four months
from the election.
Donald Trump is becoming increasingly unhinged.
There's really two ways in which voting Trump
out will only be the beginning.
Trump out as she achieves no progressive policy
like just removing Trump doesn't give progressives
any kind of policy victory.
We will only get progressive policy done if
and when Trump leaves.
If we demand it from whoever is
the next president, be it Joe Biden or be
it someone else in 2024.
The removal of Trump is the start of the possibility
of progressive policy change.
But it's not actually any policy change.
So in that sense, getting Trump out is only
the beginning.
And I've talked about that before.
But there's another side to this which is
really ugly.
And we have to sort of come to terms with
even if you remove Donald Trump, you've not
removed Trump ism. Trump ism is a virus that
is going to be around for a while.
And by Trump ism, I'm talking about all of
the really ugly stuff that we've seen for
years now, the legacy of nepotism and corruption
and the normalization of that in government.
The mainstreaming of racism and xenophobia
that existed before Trump, but it wasn't so
brazenly out in public.
That's one of
the things that Trump has done, is coalesced
and sort of said to the xenophobes and racists,
come back out into the public, come back out.
You're welcome.
Now, a ton of the behavior that people felt
ashamed about before and would keep behind
closed doors.
Now it's become almost glorified in some sense.
That won't go away the day Trump is removed.
The coarsening of language, as I call it,
you know, grab him by the You-Know-What, making
fun of people with disabilities, tweeting
white power videos.
I could go on and on and on with dozens of
examples.
That's not going to go away when Donald Trump
leaves office.
And in fact, it could actually get worse if
Donald Trump loses and claims that it was
rigged.
We might see the absolute worst of it come
out with guns to protest an election that
Donald Trump may use
to convince his followers that it was actually
rigged against him.
So if we see that type of violence, it could
get worse before it actually gets better.
And then what about Republicans?
We also have to deal with the Republicans
in the House and Senate who have been gleefully
cheering Trump, some of them.
Others have stood aside and allowed Trump
ism to take hold and run rampant.
I'm thinking of people like Susan Collins,
who's perpetually, perpetually disappointed
with Trump but doesn't actually do anything
about it.
And arguably, the enablers are just as bad
as the cheerleaders.
None of that will be removed just because
Donald Trump is removed in November.
So the point here is not to put the cart before
the horse and pretend Biden's got this thing
in the bag.
We have won nothing yet.
We're still trying to get the ball back by
removing Donald Trump in November.
If and when that happens, it could be this
November.
It could be November of 2024.
That Trump leaves, first of all.
We may have to bear the brunt of a short period
of even more chaos and violence in the streets
from people who will simply refuse to believe
that Donald Trump lost.
If, indeed, he loses in November.
But then we've got to look at the Senate.
We have to look at the House, we have to look
at governors, and we have to look at the culture
that has been created.
The culture of Trump ism.
And this is why I keep talking about we get
to vote in multiple elections in November.
We get to vote for Joe Biden.
But if you're in Arizona, you also get to
vote for Mark Kelly to replace Martha McSally.
If you're in Montana, you
get to vote for Joe Biden, but you also can
vote for Steve Bullock to be elected senator.
Amy McGrath in Kentucky.
All of these other options where we can replace
senators who have either been actually supporting
Trump or standing aside and not getting in
Trump's way.
They are all part of the problem.
And then when you look at specific issues,
you really I mean, it's hard not to be pessimistic.
You realize what we are up against.
If we remove Trump in November, we will have
lost four years.
When it comes to the environment and the climate,
we can't get those years back.
And so what that means is that we're going
to have to go above and beyond even what we
thought we would have to deal with to handle
the destruction that Donald Trump has done.
And I will go even further if even
if Joe Biden defeats Donald Trump in November,
we are going to have Trump's type candidates,
at least in 2022.
Try to get in, possibly in 2024.
So we're going to have multiple election cycles
during which we will have to resist these
malignancies so that we can try to end the
national nightmare that is Trump ism.
So, again, let's not put the cart before the
horse.
Your job is to envision that when you go to
vote in November, your vote could be the difference
maker between Trump wins your state and Biden
wins your state.
Mathematically, it's very unlikely to come
down to one vote.
But if we all have that mentality, none of
us will stay home.
We will all go out and vote.
That's number one.
We don't put the cart before the horse.
But remember that you might also be voting
on a Senate
race.
And if the right thing were to happen in November,
then and only then will we be able to say
now the work starts now.
We spend the transition period figuring out
how will we make Biden as left as possible?
How will we hold Biden accountable to the
concessions?
And there have been some that he's made to
the more progressive wing of the Democratic
Party.
That's where it all starts.
And it's going to be a very, very long battle.
So, you know, last week or the week before,
I got a phone call from a viewer saying, you
know, isn't the Senate really more important?
Because even if we remove Biden, but we don't
have the Senate, we can't do that much.
It's all important we get to vote for president
and we get to vote for senator in some states
at 35 races.
And we
get to vote for House of Representatives.
And some governors and some state reps and
states that it all matters.
It's not one or the other.
It's we should all participate and we are
going to have to resist this viral virus of
Trump ism, not only at every level in November,
but likely for a few election cycles to come.
And that is why I we just have to keep the
pressure up on all aspects of this.
We have to keep the pressure up from the perspective
of voter suppression.
We have to keep the pressure up when it comes
to the TV ads.
We have to keep the pressure up when with
these other online groups that are putting
together really good videos targeting Trump.
We don't know what it is that will make a
difference when we look back at 2016.
Was it Combs's second press
briefing about Hillary?
Was it Russian social media campaigns?
Was it Hillary not visiting Wisconsin towards
the end of the day?
You will never know the one thing.
And when you have such a complex election
with 300 in a country of 330 million, but
one hundred and twenty hundred and thirty
million votes, no one thing is ever going
to be definitively the difference maker.
These are all parts, and that's why it's so
important.
We have a fantastic program coming up for
you today.
Later on, I want to address this question
of how is Biden's lead today different than
Hillary's lead in 2016?
Nothing is a foregone conclusion, but there
are some important differences between the
polling today and the polling in 2016.
And we're going to talk about them.
We also are going to talk about what will
the debates between Trump and Biden look like?
I know that there are people convinced that
one or the other is going to absolutely implode
during the debates.
I'm not so sure we are going to talk about
that later today.
And I also I'm going to dig into.
I previewed this earlier in the week.
How does Justice John Roberts fit in ideologically
compared to the people Donald Trump has put
on the Supreme Court?
We're going to talk about the DOCA decision,
the LGBT decision and the abortion decision.
All of that coming up today.
Plus, your phone calls.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at D Pacman and make sure you are subscribed
for free to the daily audio podcast on whichever
is your favorite podcasting platform, Spotify,
iTunes, Google Play, Stitcher, your pick.
We're on Olivant.